hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
it's likely that most people are very
familiar with this catchphrase that
comes from pascals pasays the heart has
its reasons which reason does not know
and there's a lot of misunderstandings
of this the quote gets used out of
context quite often to mean something
like well you know there's reason or
intellect or cognitive capacities and
then we've got this emotional side and
that itself has reasons that reason
can't make sense of so we have to
prioritize the heart which is just this
kind of blind emotional sometimes
translations screw this up by using the
word intuition as well as you know this
this one does
it's actually a very different point
that Pascal is making and it has to do
with his notion of there being different
faculties different orders for grasping
truth and reality of things and for
getting us human beings on our way to
God to understanding God to knowing god
on the one side to loving God and
orienting ourself in the right way on
the other side and the Heart Is deeply
involved with the the latter you could
say so the full passage 277 in the
brunch fig Edition says the heart has
reasons or its reasons which reason does
not know we feel it in a thousand things
I say that the heart naturally loves the
universal B being and also itself
naturally according as it gives it makes
a gift of itself to them so done right
so it naturally loves now notice that he
says the universal being right rather
than just saying God or something like
that and itself the heart loves itself
it's a way in which the human being has
self-love
if it chooses to give itself to them so
the heart can hate itself the heart can
hate the universal being because the
next thing that he says right after this
is that it hardens itself against one or
the other the universal being or itself
seduci literally becomes hard or you
know uh tough towards them by its own
choice straw in French right so the
heart is very closely connected with
what we could also call the will and
this is going to be a quite an important
set of ideas that that are going on here
so he tells us you've rejected the one
kept the other is it by reason that you
love yourself or is it something that's
deeper and higher than reason he goes on
and then he'll talk about God
being felt or another translation here
experienced right and the two words that
are being used are coming from this uh
verb that means to feel right uh Santi
right here and then
so God is felt by the heart not by
reason it doesn't mean that reason has
no connection with God it just means
that there isn't this deep connection
it's one that's mediated more
conceptually so he says it's the heart
Which experiences God not the reason
this then is faith God is felt by the
heart not by the reason reason isn't the
sort of thing that does feeling right so
to demand that reason would feel God is
kind of a category mistake right and
he'll go on and talk about faith itself
why being a gift of God he says do not
believe that we we said it was a gift of
reasoning now a little bit earlier in
the work he's going to talk about this
as well in a a way that's quite
interesting right
this is in part 185 he says the conduct
of God who disposes all things kindly is
to put religion into the Mind by reason
and Into the Heart by Grace so it's not
as if reason plays no role whatsoever
right reason is important for the mind
let's pray in in French right which is
one of the three orders that Pascal will
talk about elsewhere but God has to put
something into the Heart by Grace by
giving something and then Pascal gives
us a caution
to put it into the mind and heart by
force and threats is not to put religion
there
but Terror so you know this is a
condemnation of some of the things that
are going on in his time uh on on the
side of both Catholics and and
Protestants
um he goes on and he's going to tell us
a little bit later that we know truth
not only it is in section 282 not only
by reason but by the heart and this is
very interesting he goes on to say it is
in this last way by the heart that we
know first principles how do we
apprehend the things that we need to use
in order to reason about the world or
about ourselves or about God or about
other people or about Society or any of
these other things he says reason has no
part in The Knowing of first principles
and it tries in vain to impugn them and
he goes on to talk about the Skeptics
which I'll pass
over here
because what he says the knowledge of
first principles as space time motion
number is as sure as any of those which
we get from reasoning and now there's a
little bit of a misleading translation
here in the English reason must trust
these intuitions of the heart now Pascal
doesn't actually say
um intuitions of the heart he actually
says knowledge is
of the heart that reason is going to
draw upon so the knowledge of first
principles right reason must trust these
and must base them on base base every
argument upon them and then he goes on
he says we have this knowledge of the
tri-dimensional nature of space the
Infinity of number and then reason shows
there are no two square numbers one of
which is double of the other
principles he's going to tell us are
felt
again translated here is intuited but
felt is a better way of translating it
propositions are inferred or concluded
right all with certainty
all with certitude but by different ways
or paths in in French so again Pascal is
not you know trying to tear down reason
or espouse a kind of irrationalism he's
saying that there's something that
exceeds reason and reason works best
when it is integrated with the heart not
trying to use serpent you could say and
he goes on after this and actually both
sides have their own legitimate
purposes right
he says it is as useless and absurd now
those are bad things for possible right
and you teal uh you know something that
is not going to help us out and then
logically absurd something that is crazy
right he says it's useless and absurd
for a reason to demand from the heart
proofs of her first principles reason
goes beyond its own bounds when it does
that and demands something from the
heart before it listens to it but the
heart can also screw up as well he says
it's as just as absurd as it would be
for the heart to demand from reason and
intuition of all demonstrated
propositions before accepting them so
each of them has their legitimate
purposes each of them has their
legitimate sides just so happens that in
pascals uh we could call it anthropology
uh or psychology the heart is going to
be more important than reason and reason
is going to be a little bit uh
uh more fallible than it than it
realizes itself right so
he goes on in 283 in a section called
order against the objection that
scripture has no order and here he
brings up two different orders he says
the heart has its own order the
intellect has its own which is by
principle and demonstration the heart
has another
we do not prove that we ought to be
loved by enumerating an order the causes
of love that would be ridiculous that
would be silly foolish
and then he brings up Jesus Christ and
Saint Paul he says Jesus Christ and
Saint Paul employ the rule of and it's
translated here as love but the French
is actually right there is an order of
Charity an order of love that Pascal
thinks is higher than the order of mere
mind or Esprit or thinking right the
intellect doesn't mean that it
contradicts it or negates it it's just
higher and can inform the lower order so
he says that Jesus Christ and Saint Paul
would warm not instruct it's the same
with Saint Augustine this order consists
chiefly in digressions on each point to
indicate the end and keep it always in
sight so that tells us something very
important there as well the the
art helps us to keep perspective about
what we're actually trying to accomplish
and then
he goes on in section 284 and says do
not want her to see simple people
believe without reasoning they believe
on the basis of their heart God imparts
to them love of him and hatred of self
he inclines their heart to believe men
will never believe without a saving in
real Faith unless God inclines their
heart a topic that will come back to in
just a moment and they will believe as
soon as he inclines it and this is what
David knew well when he said in cleaner
in now that's a reference to the Psalms
and David being one of the composers of
the psalm saying incline or turn my
heart o God towards you right so God
plays a role in the inclination of the
the heart right so let's talk about that
a bit because he brings that up earlier
in and 252
he's and there's an interesting
discussion going on here he says we must
not misunderstand ourselves we are as
much automatic as intellectual and hence
it comes that the instrument by which
conviction is attained is not
demonstrated alone how few things are
actually demonstrated proofs only
convince the Mind custom
is the source of our strongest and most
beliefs believe proofs it bends the
automaton the autonomous the automaton
is us right which persuades the mind
without it thinking about the matter who
has demonstrated there will be a
tomorrow and that we shall die and what
is more believed it's custom which
persuades US of this now custom
shouldn't be equated with the heart but
custom Works upon the heart and so you
know reason custom both of these are
ways in which he will conclude this
passage or come to the close close to
the end of it says it's not enough to
believe only by force of conviction when
the automaton is inclined to believe the
contrary both are Parts must be made to
believe the mind by reasons which it is
sufficient to have seen once in a
lifetime the automaton by custom and by
not allowing it to Incline to the
contrary in cleanup
he says once again right and so both
feeling and uh reasoning are important
in inclining the heart and inclining the
heart to what to whatever it wants no to
to God to a greater grasp on truth and
reality I'll conclude by bringing up
something that's coming up in uh 194 a
very long discussion that he has there
where again he is writing in a way that
incorporates the heart to things he says
let's recognize there's two kinds of
people one can call reasonable
now is it people who are rational all
the time depending only on rationality
no
the people that are the most reasonable
and that deserve to be called reasonable
according to Pascal are these those who
serve God with all their heart because
they know him
those who seek him with all their heart
because they do not know him so you
could know God you could not know God
what matters is the comportment of the
heart and notice that he's saying the
entire the whole heart not half of it
not a sliver of it not what you get to
at the very end of the day after you've
been occupying yourself with other
things serving God with all their heart
because they know him loving God right
those who seek him with all their heart
because they do not know him they want
to know him and this brings us back full
term to this heart having its reasons
the heart is reasonable it's just not
reasonable only in the way that the
faculty of reason is and it is
reasonable in a way that can allow
rationality to be placed into a more
encompassing and integrated
framework for Pascal